اسامه حفيظ ان ايطاليا ليه سفينه انقاذ
تابعه لمنظمه هيمانتي واحده لانسانيه
والتي تقلد ال179 مهاجرا بدخوله ميناء
صقليه والبدا بانزال الاطفال القصه
والافراد الذين يحتاجون لرعايه الطبيه
كانت سلطات رفضت السماح بدخول ثلاث سفن
اخرى تحمل 900 شخص في المياه القريبه كما
رفض وضوء المنظمه الانسانيه مالكه السفينه
مساعي السلطات للتمييز بين المهاجرين
الذين يحتاجون لرعايه الطبيه والاخرين
مؤكدين انهم جميعا انقذوا من البحر وهو ما
ياهلهم للحصول على حق الدخول الى ميناء
امن بموجب القانون الدولي
هل هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا اذا من ميناء
كتانيا في صقليه روبنهول مدير العمليات في
منظمه سوى سليمانيه المعنيه ايضا بالانقاذ
البحري اهلا بك معنا معنا بدايه هل
المعروف مصير من نزل ايدا من السفينه ومن
بقوا داخلها في اي وضع في اي حاله هم الان
تم توجهها الى هذا المكان وهو ليس مكانا
امن ولكن فقط للقيام بتقديم المساعده
الملحه لمن يحتاجون رعايه الطبيه وهذا
المكان
لم يتم فيه انزال كل هؤلاء الناس
بموجبه بموجب بمعاهداته البحار ما زال
هناك 35 شخص على متن السفينه تركوا لوحدهم
وليس هناك احترام لحقوق حمايتهم ونحاول ان
نقدم لهم افضل المساعدات لكي تتحقق
العمليات الحمايه والرعايه لهم وهؤلاء هي
الاشخاص
يخشون ان يعاد بهم المطاف الى ليبيا اذا
فمستوي الاحباط والخوف عال جدا بانهم لن
يصلوا الى مكان امن وهذا يعتبر حقا اصيلا
لهم
الاطفال الذين تم انزالهم من السفينه يعني
ماذا عن العائلات ماذا عن الاباء
الموجودين يعني تم تفريق العائلات ماذا
سيكون مصير اب مثلا يرى اطفاله ينزلون
بينما لا يسمح له هو بالنزول وايضا ما مدى
الاختلاط هل يسمح لكم ايضا باختلاط بهؤلاء
الباقيين على السفينه وتقديم المساعدات
لهم بشكل شخص ماذا يقولون
هنا فرصه الفاشل
العائلات كل من لهم افراد بالعائله يجب ان
يكونوا مع بعضهم البعض اذا من هم تركوا
الان على متن سفينه هم ليسوا افراد عائلات
بل اشخاص لوحدهم
وايضا الاطفال الذين
خرجوا من السفينه هم الان في ايطاليا
ونعمل ان تقدم لهم المساعده من الحكومه
والسلطات الايطاليه ومنظمات الرعايه
الصحيه
والان ليس لدينا معلومات عن هذا الامر الى
الان بالنسبه لنا شخص على متن السفينه نحن
على اتصال يوميا معهم ونقدم لهم الغذاء
والماء كما نقدمه المساعده وقدمناها لاشخ
الاخرين ايضا نقدم لهم محامين لكي
يستطيعوا
ان يدافعوا عن حقوقهم الدوليه وهذا ما
نقوم به الان
ونحن نقوم ايضا
بالمكافحه من اجل ان يكون لديهم حمايه
لحقوقهم الاصليه طيب ان كان هناك فرض من
قبل السلطات لامر اذا المغادره لهذه
السفينه والعوده ربما الى ليبيا يعني فيما
يعد هذا الامر الامر بالمغادره انتهاء كان
للقانون الدولي وفي حال حصل هذا الامر
وهذا السيناريو كيف يمكن ان تتصرف
مايكل
لنا بان نعود الى ليبيا بل الى المياه
الدوليه وان نغادر المياه
الاقليميه لايطاليا ونحن
لم نرضى بذلك ولن نقوم بذلك الى ان يقوم
كل شخص على متن سفينه بان نزول منها
بطريقه سليمه وامنه سيكون هناك انتهاك
لمعاهداتي جنيف وحقوق الانسان العمل على
ذلك ولن يكون الامر امنا لهذه السفينه
ولقطانها بان يغادر لذلك نحن نريد ان نضمن
بانهم يحصلوا على الحمايه الدوليه التي
يستحقون ايضا قدمنا
سبايدر مان
للمحكمه المحليه ضد الحكومه الايطاليه
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من الصقليه من كتانيا
تحديدا حيث ترسه هيمانتي واحد التي سمح
لها بانزال بعض اركبها مدير العمليات في
منظمه اسا واس في معناته